تفاجات النجم الكنديه العالميه سيلين ديون
العالم كله من ايام باعلان محزن ومؤثر
نشرته عبر حسابها على انستغرام وفي بتعلن
عن اصابتها بمرض عصبي نادر اسمه متلازمه
الشخص المتيبس اضطرها انها تعلق جولتها في
ربيع 2023 وتاجلها ل 2024 وانها تلغي بشكل
كامل ثمانيه من حفلاتها في الصيف 2013 من
وقت هذا الاعلان المؤلم واسم الفنانه في
العناوينز ونهله تتمنيات بالشفاء عليها من
مختلف مشاهير العالم ومحبيها والجمهور
العام كمان ومع هذا تداول الخبر زاد البحث
بشكل كبير عن متلازمه الشخص المتلبس
وملايين من حول العالم صاروا بيتساءلوا عن
هذا المرض النادر
واسباب الاصابه فيه وغيرها من التفاصيل
عنهم في تفاعل
استعان بالدكتوره منى عبد الفتاح ندى
استاذه امراض المخ صعب لا تشرح لنا اكثر
عن هذا المرض خليني انت متابعه ما هو
متلازمه الشخص المتلبس او السيفرسون
الحقيقه ده مرض نادر جدا حدوثه بيحصل واحد
في المليون يصيب النساء اكثر ليس له سبب
معروف لغايه دلوقت مش عارفين سببه بيحصل
مشكله في المناعه ان المناعه تعلى فتبتدي
تصيب او تؤثر على ماده اسمها جلوتاميك
اسيد ديرب الماده دي دورها انها توصل
للجهاز العصبي الاشارات العصبيه فبتدي
العضله تتحرك لما بيحصل خلل في المناعه
يبتدي يحصل مشكله في المخ وفي النخاع
الشوكي فتبتدي تدي اعراض كثيره للمريض
ايه هي اعراض المرض ده بيحصل تيبس شديد في
العضلات وتبتدي العضلات الجذعيه اللي لها
علاقه بالصدر والبطن اللي اول عضلات تتاثر
وبعد كده بالسين طويله يبتدي يتاثر الساق
والذراع يحصل ايه للمريض يبقى فيه صعوبه
في الحركه شديده حساسيه شديده جدا للصوت
او لللمس تختفي الاعراض تماما اثناء النوم
طيب هل له خطوره على المريض او هو مرض
قاتل هو خطورته انه بيعمل اعاقه مع تقدم
المرض يبتدي يحصل صعوبه في الحركه قد تؤدي
الى احتياج المريض لمساعده من الاخرين
وتحتاج الى اعانه طول الوقت لكنه ليس مرض
قاتل
هل هيستمر وليس له علاج علاج ينقسم
الحقيقه لادويه لها علاقه بالمناعه فبتدي
تدي دواء زي الاي في اي جي او
انيونوجلوبين بتعمل اعاده لتنظيم المناعه
بتاعت الجسم او بنعمل فصل بلازما وبندي
دواء اسمه بكل دي ادويه بتشتغل على
المناعه جزء ثاني من العلاج اللي احنا
بندي ادويه بواسط للعضلات فالتيبس الشديد
المريضه بتحس به يبتدي يتحسن الجزء الثالث
من العلاج اللي احنا بنعمل علاج طبيعي ما
فيش حاجه كافيه شافيه تماما من المرض هو
بيفضل يستمر الى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد علاج
تام وشافي تماما ولكنها كلها محاولات
لتعديل المناعه اللي حصل فيها خلل فتبتدي
يكون اقل ضرر للمريض
[موسيقى]